become one of the thorniest debates in
society today should trans women
athletes be allowed to compete in
women's sport well who's better to talk
to frankly an olympic gold medalist as a
male ashley and i'm gonna be the most
famous trans woman in the world now
caitlyn jenner caitlyn i'm so happy to
have you on the show thank you very much
well it is my pleasure but first pierce
let's let's clear the air here um
i was asked to do this show like a month
ago
in the last couple of weeks i saw and i
wound up canceling about two weeks ago
why because i saw what she did to
president trump our president who i have
a lot of respect for um and like he was
walking out you sensationalize the promo
to build up ratings and all this and i i
thought to myself i don't want to be
part of that and so i canceled but since
then um and i stand by what i did but
since then we've had a chance to talk
talk to your producers i feel pretty
confident that you won't do that to me
i'm not going to over socialize this
caitlyn at all i'm delighted to have got
you back on the show and all i would say
about the promo is i know donald trump
through celebrity apprentice which i won
and he did those kind of promos on me
every night to get people watching so
all's fair in love in promo
however however let's turn let's turn to
the main event of this this interview
you you're perfectly qualified caitlyn
to talk about this because i have a
strong view that i support trans rights
to fairness and equality but in issues
like sport and women's sport not to the
point where it starts to degrade the
fairness and equality for women
competitors in in sport for example
you've competed as a man hugely
successfully um and now you've
transitioned to be a woman what is your
view about this
well i've been you know first of all
you're right we have to uh we have to do
the best we can here but
um i have said from the beginning and i
stand with it that i don't want
biological boys to compete against women
and girls in sports it's just not fair
now obviously over the last
six months especially
because of leah thomas
at the university of pennsylvania
she had been on the boys team just a few
years earlier
i do not blame her
she played within the rules
but she dominated
she had gone through male puberty her
lungs are bigger her back's bigger her
hands are bigger she just has a
tremendous advantage in swimming in the
pool against the women and you know and
she proved that
um so i don't have a problem with her i
have a problem with the ncaa um
that we have to change the rules
we have to do a better job because the
bottom line is
we have to keep it fair and i don't want
to ruin women's sports or discourage
women from getting into sports because
they think oh my gosh i'm going to have
to compete against a bunch of guys i
mean i totally agree it's not fair i
totally agree kaitlyn but what i would
also say is i don't want to expose trans
people to mockery which is now going on
with this debate because it looks so
ridiculous that you see leah thomas just
dominating women's sport and i think
that trans people who don't want to be
part of any big angry debate about this
want to go about their lives in peace
and quiet and get on with it i think
they're being affected adversely by this
debate and it seems to me nobody's
prepared to put the herd over the
parapet and go look this is clearly
unfair and wrong here's how we're going
to change things if you were in charge
of changing things to make it fair what
is the answer should trans women
athletes for example compete against men
should trans athletes have their own
category now of competition given there
are more and more trans athletes what's
the answer
well here's pierce here's here's the
problem we have here this is a very very
complicated issue just like being trans
is very complicated um it's very it's
there's no right there's no right answer
here pierce um if you just say
you know no trans athletes um you know
in sports
well what about female to male
they're trans that's 49 of the
population 51 percent are male to female
if we
what happens to the young
trans
athletes who transitioned some of them
when they're five six seven years old
they take uh hormone
blockers and they grow up as little
girls their whole life they have no
advantage whatsoever you know over the
other girls and what do we do there so
it almost has to be treated on an
individual basis but i think the first
thing we have to do is we
we have to make the qualifying for a
trans athlete a little bit more
difficult for them to be able to compete
because i think the number one thing we
have to do is protect
women's sports i mean you never see
sports well you never see you you
mentioned there people who transition
from female to male but you never see
any issue there on the sporting side
because they never have an unfair
advantage you know the key point really
about i guess trans women athletes is
they have an unfair natural biological
advantage that's the number of the
problem
if they went through male puberty yeah
you're absolutely right
i went through male puberty okay
i mean i don't even play i mean i play a
lot of golf yeah and at our club i mean
i play with the women a lot by the way
appears the women a lot more fun to play
with than the men but the conversation's
much better but they always ask you know
say hey we've got a tournament coming up
yeah we've got a tournament coming up
you want to play with us and you know
when i'm there i say oh well that would
be fun but then i never show up why
because it's just honestly it's i don't
i would never want to take a trophy away
from one of the other i love the ladies
at our club they're wonderful i wouldn't
want to take i can out drive them by a
hundred yards yeah exactly you know and
yeah
yeah and it's just my arms are longer
i'm six one
um what i got left over is more than
what most people ever had
and so i it just wouldn't be fair
so
i don't play in that to be honest with
you leah thomas is
you know honestly leah thomas is one of
the
toughest of one of the hardest uh
one of the worst things that happened to
the trans community yeah i agree because
it's such
bad publicity yeah i've met so many
wonderful trans people doing wonderful
things living their life authentically i
hope leah thomas it's over for her now
because she's out of out of college and
i just hope she has a wonderful life
being trans is not easy um and i hope
she enjoys the rest of her life and has
a good life you know what really
complete what leah did is we need to
look at the rules i agree listen i
completely agree with you i don't want i
want ill will to anyone involved in mr b
i just want fairness and equality i
don't want women's women's rights to be
eroded at the altar of political
correctness and a scaredness to have a
debate caitlyn we've got to leave it
there it's been a brilliant uh interview
thank you come back soon i'd love to
talk to you again i want you the regular
game
pleasure
yeah absolutely all right i think we'll
have fun it's really good
you got it lovely to thoughty caitlyn
jenner